the hashtag freethe21 has brought
international condemnation for
ghana the 21 are lgbt activists who were
detained in late may
the 16 women and five men have been
charged with illegal assembly because
they organized and attended a training
event we went to ho in southeastern
ghana from where dw's
africa's isaac allegedy sent us this
report
angel maxine is transgender she came out
publicly
more than five years ago since then
maxine has been
a woman
magazine is one of very few lgbt people
in ghana
speaking out publicly about their
sexuality
and gender identity but with that
bravery
comes constant humiliation abuse and
discrimination from the society around
here
one time i went to the market to go and
buy stuff for myself like
footsteps and all that and when i
entered the market and people realized
who i was they started hooting at me
hooting at me insulting me why are you a
man and you want to be like this why
this graciousness you are the people who
have brought poverty to ghana
yeah somebody even said that was the
reason why his salary has reduced
where i knew him from nowhere you know
and it touched my heart i'm like
why are these people condemning me
whatever i stood in the market and i
cried
[Music]
through music maxine is able to express
her feelings
about life as an lgbt person in ghana
and those feelings were sadness and
outrage
after the arrest of 21 activists
at an lgbt rights workshop in ghana's
voter region
police accused them of unlawful assembly
after the arrest they were detained for
days without trial
a judge denied a bill application for
their release
many of them suffered physically and
mentally
behind bars their condition
i would say is bad it doesn't look good
there are others who are not well in
terms of
psychosocial they are depressed there
are others who
have ulcer there are those who have
children that they haven't been able to
see their children
some of some people are equally like
married and haven't been able to see
their family and all human rights
lawyers say
the continued detention of the 21 is
unlawful previously it used to be the
case that there were certain offences
that
you could not get bill from at all that
has been scrapped
due to a case that went before the
supreme court
and so at this point there's no such
offense however
the law still stands that under
uh laws or criminal procedure code you
know
there are certain things that the court
is supposed to consider in awarding view
in this case bill was denied as
prosecutors
asked for more time ghana is still a
hostile place for lgbt people
homophobic abuse and violence are
widespread
but activists say giving up now is not
an option
they want an end to all forms of hatred
towards minorities in the country
little by little i feel like certain
groups minority groups
in ghana are going to be harassed
intimidated arrested extorted from
somehow
so it's not far at all some of these
people
in here today the 21 people being held
legally
are your neighbors some of them came
from accra some of them are just the
school teachers some of them are
doctors some of them they work
efficiently in different aspects of
society
despite the threats maxine is still
pushing for acceptance
with hopes for a future where just
walking on the street
won't come with fear of getting arrested
and detained